Oscar is this obviously a lot of people
don't know much about the film what I
have heard is that you get to sort of
play some comedy with Harrison Ford as
Han Solo is that do you ever you have
some lighter moments in between things
you know I'd get some good good
Harrison Ford moments I remember that if
for me that the hair was a big thing
because it can be very curly and they
wanted it not to be too curly and there
you know there was a lot of adjusting of
the hair and getting your areas here no
mine oh and I remember one time I was
standing there and I felt somebody just
here staring him and I look and it's
Harrison and he's just looking up my
hair and he's like no no it's my hair
and then he did this face I don't really
remember what it is it was somewhere
between disdain and also impressed
didn't you ask him about the
aerodynamics of flying an x-wing fighter
I did I did because I you know I had
never done anything like that before and
I was asking him you know so what how
did you do what did he do and I know
you're a great pilot so can you tell me
something about that and he says it's
fake and it's in space
hey thanks for watching be sure to click
subscribe to see even more great Conan
clips you may now return to your pirated
movies and creepy Japanese pornography